[Musique]
nous sommes chez christophe leroy mungo
camarades et japon
une truffe d'ailleurs nous allons la
reprendre avec christophe quelques
semaines car nous avons rarement une
très très belle culié christophe et moi
allons réaliser des jeunes et des dîners
d'exception
il faudra absolument d'europa l'envol
soirée et vive la république
c'est un scandale qui depuis 72 heures
agite les médias et les réseaux sociaux
pour l' affaire dite des dîners
clandestins des dîners luxueux dîner
dans un luxueux restaurant dans la
capitale
la mise en lumière de soirées
clandestines organisé en plein
confinement par des figures de notoriété
publique
tout commence vendredi lorsque le
journal de la soirée m6 le 19 45 diffuse
un reportage en caméra cachée sur les
coulisses d'une soirée clandestine
organisé en plein confinement dans les
beaux quartiers de la capitale
le jeudi 1er avril dîner et bal au
palais vive il ne se sent il ya un bal
120 euros par personne coupe de
champagne crédit crêpes vonnas sienne ça
parce que c'est selon et caviar oeuf
mimosa au caviar tartare de thon et
caviar loup vapeur salle des marques
caviar gâteau de pommes de terre et
cédric tout ça c'est maintenant le dîner
au caviar
je veux dire que si d'aventuré il y
avait des ministres ou des députés qui
aurait enfreint les règles eh bien il
faut qu'ils aient des amendes et qu'ils
soient pénalisés comme chaque citoyen
liste l'économie bruno le maire lui il
est allé encore plus loin
il a même été jusqu'à demander ce que
les noms sortent les gens qui mentent
les gens qui sont malhonnêtes qui font
semblant
ça me dégoûte je peux même pas rester
dans la même pièce que lui parce que j'y
vais vomir
la réunion qui a vu dernièrement c'est
avec 1 0 je pense le label emi dalle qui
nous est nord ne les écoutez pas mon
dieu je sais pas ils ne savent pas ce
qu'ils jouaient bien ça fait trois
grains minable d'un mauvais calmez vous
avez il fallait captée par le pâté et
leur fournit plus rien sur ces images
que nous nous sommes procurés une
quarantaine de convives sans masquer
certains se font la bise
si les visages sont floutés les voit
transformé la journaliste précise que
l'organisateur est un célèbre
collectionneur
ce collectionneur renommée se défend et
dénonce une pratique généralisée très
vite des internautes pensent savoir de
qui il s'agit et cite le nom de pierre
jean chalencon sur les réseaux
après plusieurs heures de silence par le
biais de son avocat messieurs chalencon
a reconnu être la personne interviewée
dans le reportage de m6 il est cette
semaine dans deux ou trois restaurants
qui sont justement d'ailleurs des
restaurants aux auckland est avec un
certain nombre de ministres alors ça me
fait doucement rigoler on est encore en
démocratie on fait ce qu'on veut elle
pas les villiers mais bon on peut il
mettre des lumières on peut donc que sa
bulle et heureusement qu'on peut faire
ça mettra un côté ça serait ça très
grave si on ne pouvait pas faire ça non
je sais pas c'est bon ça va ça fait 15
mois qu'ils nous emmerdent alors vous
pouvez gagner 1500 euros par mois
pendant un an soit 18 mille euros c'est
pas rien quand même
18000 euros et en plus nets d'impôts et
bientôt un mets dedans pour les 18 lots
pour vous dire dans les tares pour une
fois de la légion de ma bondissant les
drapeaux à s'affairer le sang je vais
profiter de cette petite occasion pour
faire
je vais me mettre dehors
même si vous attendez tous à cabinda
[Musique]
ça me faire un dessin pour parler
poliment basso s'ils ont tous choisi
donc franchement on dirait des vrais
noms mais c'est super la culotte
touchant rembourrés rios et augmente le
volume de votre post est rien tout en
s'adaptant à sa forme naturelle portions
régime toi tout le temps qu'on va parler
des régimes dans un hangar est autant ri
j'ai tout essayé et y'a rien qui
émaillent en a qui marche
mécontent c'est non
alors j'en ai un si je peux en faire de
ce soir et de demain à [ __ ] trois
tenues ce qui est bien avec daisy de
trois antennes vers à voile oui allez
dans ma tête oui je suis dans sa tête
vous rentrez entre elle et moi vous
assumez les pots cassés résultat d'un
classement mis au point par gleeden un
site anti giddens fondu faith si je ne
connais voilà un site dédié aux
rencontres extraconjugales et la
plateforme a calculé donc le ratio entre
le nombre d'habitants par ville et le
nombre d'inscrits sur le site
et c'est donc lille qui arrive en tête
avec un taux d'1 6 d'élite et de 29%
j'ai été trahi par l'un de mes ex et
vous en guise de vengeance j'avais ces
photos donc deux parties vous et perd le
bas c'est sur les réseaux sociaux non
non bien pire j'ai imprimé des flyers et
j'ai distribué dans un centre commercial
de lyon ou ou comme ces violents peu
mauvais goût
un tiers des lillois sera infidèle les
parisiens ne pas de jaloux les parisiens
sont deuxièmes suivis par les bordelais
les lyonnais quand même le studio aussi
dans le top 10 versailles rouen nantes
rennes montpellier et strasbourg
[Musique]
raisons d'être content d'y aller en
famille merci beaucoup
charlotte ne vous inquiétez pas al-azhar
notre rédacteur en chef a vengé mexique
est bien sûr vous voulez bien nous
occupe
comment ça d'antonio déjà bonsoir vme
automnaux bonsoir il est dans le truc ça
y est il est dans là il est dans la
téloche anthony ya beaucoup de gens qui
te vous croyez qu'on croyait qu antonio
n'est encore non public voulait parce
que l'habitude des banques publiques
antonio de btp je suis là non plus il
marque pas j'adore parce qu'il n'ya pas
un micro qui marche donc anthony on va
faire le tour de table
et pendant ce temps on va équiper un
t'inquiète pas on a des micros il ya un
magasin qui ont ouvert jusqu'au bac à
droite c'est un duplex tout ce qu'il ya
de plus classique sur la météo à moscou
en direct à la télévision
tout est bien qui finit bien quelques
minutes plus tard la journaliste a
récupéré son micro un peu mordu et a pu
terminer son intervention en bonne
compagnie oui alors vous comprenez alors
attendez attendez il paraît qu'il ya que
moi qui ai un micro pour l'instant tout
a sauté ya que moi qui peut parler eh
ben je suis tout seul à terminer debout
non est ce un panneau planté
comment on se sent jamais dit pour vous
souhaiter une excellente façon de france
en guinée clandestins sévit à oui
attention banques font attention c'est
nur ahmed se fâche et kebabs numérique